the Northeast Corridor that acello line
I call that the corridor of hate because
everyone is so angry on that line right
and so it's how many fights I've been in
the state of Maryland it's an angry
place oh my gosh the whole Northeast is
like that I remember one time I was in
Nantucket my wife and I were in a bar
and we're like this is very preppy and I
was like what's that Bell for and
they're like well and there's a fight we
ring the bell so the the bouncers know
to come in and I'm looking around and
it's all just rich people in preppy
outfits and I'm like how often ding ding
and there's just these These Guys in
like these Nantucket pink
watching each other and you're like what
is going on